Now, in this section, we're going to begin with a discussion about working with cinecamera
actors.
Starting out, we're going to look at Unreal Engine's camera basics.
When working with cinecamera actors, you're generally going to find that there are two
main camera actor types.
The first camera actor is the cinecamera actor, which is the most common camera used in film
productions or other linear content projects.
The cinecamera actor was specifically built to emulate a real-world physical camera inside
Unreal Engine.
It is very similar to the other camera actor type, but with some additional cinematic film
controls such as film back, lens, focus tracking, and post-process, among others.
The game camera actor is the most common camera actor found in games, and because of its simplicity,
this is more often used as the player's view camera.
The only real control here is your field of view, and unlike the cinecamera, those extra
cinematic camera controls are not available on the game camera actor.
Now there are a few ways to actually add camera actors into your levels.
The first does not require an active level sequence.
Simply navigate over to the Place Actors tab, select the Cinematic section, and drag the
cinecamera actor into your level.
One thing to note here is that when you place your cinecamera actor from this tab into your
level, it is a possessable actor, and can be dragged from the outliner into any active
level sequence.
Another way to add cinecamera actors to any active level sequence is to click on the camera
icon, and that will automatically add a spotable cinecamera actor, and once that camera is
active in a level or through sequencer, you will have access to the camera actor details
panel.
The details panel has several camera settings that we want to look at, and the most notable
settings are the ones for the cinecamera.
Settings such as the film back presets, which allows you to select a specific type of film
back, or to manually adjust your camera sensor aspect ratios, width, and height.
Next are the lens settings, and it is here that you can adjust your focal length, f-stop,
apply a squeeze factor that will allow you to emulate the look of an anamorphic lens,
or adjust the diaphragm blade count.
Set that lower to have a polygonal shape, or higher to create a soft, more rounded shape
for your bokeh.
You'll also find focus settings for the cinecamera here, that allow you to set manual focus distance,
activate the debug focus plane, which is a very important tool that I will demonstrate
a little later, and the focus offset.
Similar to the focus settings, there are also tracking settings, such as enabling look at
tracking, that we will look at more in depth in another section of this course.
Finally, there are also several post-process options connected to the cinecamera, allowing
for post-process control to be added to the cinecamera directly.
Last, there is one very important topic left to discuss when working with cinecamera actors
in Sequencer, and that is the use of the camera cuts track.
Every single cinecamera that gets added to Sequencer must be bound to the camera cuts
track, which controls the active camera being viewed through the assigned camera bindings.
Note, the camera binding IDs can be changed in the properties for any specified camera
in your camera cuts track, by right-clicking on the camera cut track, and making the connections
through the camera cuts track properties.
Without a camera cuts track, the cameras in your level will not be active in the cinematic
view, resulting in being unable to render the cinecamera.
Okay, that's it for this section of working with cinecamera actors.
In our next section, we will take a quick look at the camera components available to
use with Sequencer.